we're not feel this Cody calling from
Michigan I got a question for you Raya I
was just wondering what he thinks about
this [ __ ] Muppet Logan Paul thinking
that he can fight sage Northcutt I just
want to get a little bit insight see
what see what kind of [ __ ] joke this
is that guy should be a promoter have
him out on the promotional changes side
do that ironically and I hate to you
know cuz that guy's obviously on my side
of that sage would win the fight yeah um
Logan Paul was a high level wrestler a
lot of people know that he's also a big
athletic guy he's a 185-pound in high
school Wow 185 pounds in LA high school
then he took six in the state of Ohio
which is one of the toughest states yeah
sage on the other hand has been fighting
as a career Logan's been doing the you
know social-media influencer thing and
everything else but the mindset man that
is the most important thing sage has it
Logan has it LO gonna be a big
disadvantage obviously and the stand up
and everything else but they always want
to see sage go against wrestlers because
he's not from a wrestling background
they think that's his weakness etc and
Logan Paul has been boxing for fawni and
said their social media guys and
everything else but he believes in
himself and I actually know Logan Paul
and I text him after his fight and then
I text him with him and say start
talking crap to each other and I think
it could happen yeah I think it
happening I don't think it'll happen in
the UFC mm-hmm sage is now a free agent
but but unless Logan doesn't want to
fight him but I think he I think he
believes in himself I mean right he
comes off as a guy that believes in
himself right you know he told me I'm a
skull crusher Dana said he would he'd be
you know he should be put in jail if he
lets Logan Paul fight in the UFC yeah I
told Logan that lug was like I'm a skull
crusher dangerous know what he's talking
about so he really believed he might
earn it he believes himself he's only 23
Sage's 21 I was 23 24 when I started
training for fighting with just a
wrestling back
just wrestling yeah and who are we if we
knocked somebody that believes in
themself yeah you know so I mean I I
know that he has a lot of haters and I
appreciate this guy honoring the fact
that UFC is real and it is real and it's
it's a very difficult thing to get to
but the fact that he's got 17 million
followers and he really believes himself
and he's willing to put it out there
that's brave if he really is willing to
be put it out there because there's one
thing to say it there's nothing to
actually step in the ring with a sage
Northcutt and say all right let's let's
throw fisticuffs but I think it could
happen and what do you think the odds
would be like what odds with it like
what you know what would Vega said well
the Vegas odds would start highly in
sages favor logan paul would talk
himself up and he has 17 million
followers and odds are are sometimes
proceeding all the time depending on
who's betting what money so he might be
the favorite at the end of it if he has
enough people who's gonna win you could
you could be the one to promote that and
i feel like yeah well we've been talking
a little bit there you go
i mean but not to talk about everyone in
the in the picture i I think getting
Logan to actually want to fight right
saying you want two fights one thing
actually doing it's another but it's all
you but you know what's interesting is
that it's funny like how having one I
could see I could really not I could see
this you have one career as a social
media influence or writing you've had
this you've kind of grown up in this in
this YouTube space and have millions and
millions of fans and now you want to
prove yourself in a different area of
your life we would all go to a skill set
we already have some you know like if I
didn't do stand-up maybe I would try to
get into um you know something else that
I could you know I would probably I
would pick a skill set that I have right
and work on that so one of his obviously
good skill sets is wrestling and I would
say I don't know Logan to this level and
I'm sure he's worked very hard to build
his following now doing whatever he's
been doing yeah pissing people off a lot
of times he's been consistent yeah
growing up and being watch yeah be a
while but I guarantee you if you asked
him what with the things he's worked on
hardest on his life have been it's
probably the most focused and dedication
has
towards wrestling - cuz I know the
wrestling world and I know guys like
that believe in themselves yeah and I
and I and I you know I know about a
state like Ohio which takes Russia very
very serious yeah so you know I think
sage and Logan could happen yeah Wow I'd
watch it I bet it would start out of
seven to one and I bet it would maybe
break I would bet it could be even at
some point yeah I don't wanna take a
little bit dude yeah well look but I'll
tell you what and Knicks lost a lot of
money yeah that's very company but no
it's interesting you look at it's
interesting because where would you go
you've already done something to it to
it height yeah you know and also he's
the the thing about the world he's in is
you have no way of defending yourself
from haters right you either like me
here I don't and there's no like well I
I mean I think that's why Logan really
enjoyed the process of having that fight
because he got to like defend himself
really because he is just a kid growing
up in a world that's really judgmental
and he's done some things that have
pissed some people off but at the end of
the day he's a human being who works
really really hard who has some talents
agree and he got to go out there and and
he does it didn't matter what anybody
thought he's gonna go punch someone in
the face and pretty admirable yeah and
it is out you know what's amiable even
if you want whether win or lose it's
admirable yeah I think what needs to
happen is that fight needs to happen
with sage and Logan and Logan I I've
mentioned this you know raising some
awareness for a charity yeah that'd be a
cool thing yeah you can do it yeah he's
gonna so much power good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one